we don't usually do entertainment
stories on this show but i do want to
talk about something that happened last
night comedian dave chappelle was
attacked on stage by an individual
believed to be armed while performing at
the la hollywood bowl
there are a number of different videos
from audience members cell phones which
started to flood social media
and they showed a man a man appeared to
run onto stage the stage and tackle
dave chappelle
lapd told cbs la that it was a 23 year
old man armed with a replica handgun
that contained a knife blade arrested
and accused of assault with a deadly
weapon uh police identified him as
isaiah lee and
we're holding him on thirty thousand
dollars bail dave chappelle reportedly
not injured in the attack we're not
gonna show a picture of the attacker
being brought out his arm uh is
completely mangled as a result of how he
was handled by security and uh that type
of imagery is is not allowed on many of
our platforms um there is a joke
that was made by chris rock now this is
just sort of a strange random thing
chris rock who was slapped by will smith
at the oscars recently was in attendance
and he came up and uh told the following
joke after the incident
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so people having a good time with
that um so why am i talking about this
listen
we cannot have a culture where this is
okay
all right now
initially
it was sort of like uh
asserted without evidence that the
attacker was a trans man attacking dave
chappelle
for chappelle's recently controversial
comments on transgenderism in a netflix
special that that has not been
demonstrated right now
and if it was asserted without evidence
and it puts the spotlight on trans
people who may have nothing to do with
this and even if this was a trans person
to group trans people under what one
person did that's that's absolutely
terrible if that happened okay but we
can't have a culture where it is even
remotely acceptable to do this now i'm
not saying we do
people were
mostly booing this individual they were
supportive of dave chappelle people
mostly have not been supportive of will
smith slapping chris rock
but this is the type of thing where
violence begets violence
and then it creates the need for you
know even more security
at sporting events the same thing has
been going on there was a recent nba
game i apologize i don't have the
details it might have been the milwaukee
bucks i'm not sure
where people were running onto the court
and i think there might have been some
animal rights connection related to the
owner of the team or
i don't have the details but it's this
sort of thing where people were showing
up and to demonstrate against the owner
they were running onto the court and
trying to approach players and then so
you see even more security and then you
see even rougher treatment of people who
uh attempt to enter the field of play
we are seeing people being assaulted
for saying things that others don't like
now i want to make a a clear line here
um i am sensitive to the idea
that
sometimes there are forms of speech that
are violent towards groups of people
okay so you can make the case that
banning abortion which is a legislative
act that a state can do this has been a
it's a big topic so i'm choosing this
one you could say banning abortion is a
form of violence against women i'm
sensitive to that i am absolutely
sensitive to that
uh but we're not going to solve it by
showing up and attacking the legislators
we're going to solve it by voting all of
them out putting in legislators that
will legalize abortion that's the path
forward and we could always say yeah but
the the but it's gerrymandering and it's
stacked against us well then we got to
fix that i have not seen evidence that
just physically attacking the
individuals who say the things we don't
like is an acceptable means of change
and i recognize the difference between
the action of banning abortion versus
dave chappelle saying something in a
special people don't like those are two
different things i don't believe
violence is going to be the solution in
either and so we all have to condemn
this stuff we can condemn the things
dave chappelle said
but we also have to condemn the violence
and uh it's
i don't like the direction that this is
going
and uh i want to hear from you in the
audience uh as to your perspective on
what i think is an unfortunately growing
trend one of our sponsors today is
cheese butter i love this stuff cheese
butter is a delicious gourmet cheese
melt that ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial cheese on bread right i mean
come on and butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry and you'll
now get 20 off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below